so what's the podcast name sam
recording yeah sam
tripoli's podcast um
why would you why should we ever
as a gaster it's a meta thing it's like
oh we're calling our podcast someone
else's name yeah that's
like wow well yeah so
we would get all the sam tripoli fans
we're looking for and then what
once we have them then they stay
and they rise up against him
we create a coup and we
uh overthrow the trip
tripoliness chipotle dude okay here's
what i want to say
there's this guy at chipotle that i want
to be fired like i really
i like i hate i hate him so much that's
your goal in life is to get this guy
fired he's like this old i've told you
about this guy he's like this old guy
this old white guy who just doesn't he
just doesn't put
[ __ ] in it like he's just like like he's
like
he put like so like little [ __ ]
in the bowl and like i didn't even get
guacamole because it wasn't even worth
it
like it was just like there's nothing in
here like it would
be mostly guacamole like and
he's just like he's just like and he was
like trying to joke him around with me
like like being like hey like he's like
you know when like someone's like trying
to be like oh you know
out of the weather yeah not giving you
enough food
oh i think i ate this last last tuesday
hahaha
and i'm like don't try to joke around
with me after you just [ __ ] me
like you like
it's i'm not gonna joke around with you
this isn't a joking
mood if you just didn't give me anything
yeah
you don't deserve it you don't deserve
that you're like can you put more in
because then where do you where does
that end i like he was like uh
he was like oh do you want anything more
from this section i was like i was like
fajitas but like i kind of mumbled a
little bit
yeah and uh do you want to come over
here
what are you doing i don't know how to i
should get
i don't know this is a i'll just sit up
okay um
and then uh and then he was just like
and so like i mumbled it a little bit
and he like he repeated the question
back to me but it was the wrong question
it was like it was like
oh can i put more of it like he like he
thought
that's what i said because he knew what
he was doing
he knew what he was doing so like he
that he that immediately went to his
mind as the first question i would ask
and then he was like prepared to say no
he's like can i put more on
like like you know when someone's like
you can kind of feel the answer to the
question like when someone's asking
or you know what yeah and he's such an
[ __ ] dude
so he's used to hearing people say that
oh
i bet i mean like you should yeah go
through it and be like i'm not paying
for that
i like i legitimately thought about it
but luckily it was like
it was like not normally how much it is
because of guacamole it was like eight
something i was like oh damn that's not
terrible it's not that bad without the
guacamole it's so shitty
because in chipotle it's all up to the
dude pouring it
like that's where it bottlenecks right
and there's been a standard i've been
used to a chipotle where it's just
packed i mean maybe he's the only one
following the standard
yeah maybe he's measured it he's got the
perfect draw he's always got
practicing at home
you must be one with the chicken
feel the weight in your fingers
just like
that it's a dance uh
yeah i know man it's really upside there
and like a hair stylist to be like
can i get barbarella today
what when you get in there it could be
like no no no
big mistake huge
just ask for a different chipotle i'm
i'm
i'm actually going to stop going to that
chipotle because he's always there
he doesn't have a life he's probably
doing this for fun honestly his torture
really seems like he wants like you know
like some people
need to he needs it some people need to
help society a lot and some people
need to make a difference a lot like
that's not necessarily the same thing
like some people get off on the fact
that they made things
different not that they made it better
but that they made an impact on the
world they're like oh [ __ ]
i exist look what i yeah that's so true
dude
and they make shitty things yeah because
they don't really care about making it
better they just care about
making it doing it their mark yeah what
oh
and that's like oh that's so sad and so
disgusting
that's the only thing you're going to
take from this world is that you made a
difference
even though it wasn't but isn't that
what isn't that what we're doing though
no not at all
or like anyone like who anyone who like
gets a job
and it's just like gets a house and
they're like i don't really care
i don't really care uh about much but
like i have my house i have this house i
have my space
i have my cat
and they're just gonna live a good life
yeah i mean i mean there's nothing wrong
with that
but like yeah just don't [ __ ] people
over
yeah if you have to like go around and
change things just to change it
but if you're living a nice comfortable
life and you're trying not to make a
negative impact that's great hopefully
you're trying to make a positive impact
yeah like hitler was trying to
but with grace yeah do you think he knew
what he was doing
that's kind of sad
but anyway uh
let's talk about you know christian
things
if you just like [ __ ] destroy people
and you get to create a new country than
i was just [ __ ] awesome
i'm sure if it works out
um what are you doing
i'm just gonna hold it like without the
base
no shaft yeah
uh so
what uh
i mean so [ __ ] chipotle
yeah so uh have you read a disney world
ever
have i ever been yeah i think so
i don't know it sure reminds me of
disney world it looks like the thing
from mulan
they have a mulan ride
they have a mulan uh
it's a egg race
hair greys that's a great
aircraft's festival
every year it's an egg roll
you roll your asian taco
asian burrito do you like i mean i like
egg rolls do you
yeah yeah but um
they have a creamy interior so like
there's a
there's this place in my hometown that
you get egg rolls but it's just
cabbage inside is that a popular thing
i would still get it because it was like
i liked the breading of it but it's
right like just cabbage
yeah i mean asian people sometimes do
that they like put
like this disgusting thing in this
awesome exterior like look we can make
this edible why don't you try to make
like an edible thing
more awesome instead of like making a
bad thing barely edible
yeah like uh gluten-free [ __ ]
like super guess that's good i guess
it's healthy
like scientifically engineered it tastes
like the real thing
yeah like poco like uh beyond burger
yeah beyond beef it's beyond
beef
to the beef and beyond
um it's impossible
burger it's a it's impossible
could it be a burger it's all it's
beyond
beef it's
this is mission impossible this is
this is a a relic to men
look at the folly of man um but like why
if like vegetarians like why do you like
why do you you want it to taste like
meat so you actually
do like the taste of meat they're
admitting that that's ideal
they're they like it they like
uh yeah yeah they want a meat they want
a meat thing
in their dish yeah they realize how
awesome it is
but that they're doing doing this even
though it's not the best thing in the
world
they're like still stuck up about it
like
no i just don't like it but they still
think they deserve the taste of it
um
or maybe it's like rigatone
or angel hair it's just like a different
style of food like oh let me try the
meat style of food
well they like they they keep trying it
they're
they come back for more there's so many
meat alternatives and there's one
there's a like
they're all over the place they're at
like fast food i restaurants choose but
there's a spiritual component to eating
that they're getting satisfied by
that isn't the physical to them it's all
mental like your brain can trick you
into thinking it's delicious
um i mean it's not bad yeah it's not bad
oh but give it a shot
there yeah they have this like beyond
beef
tortilla is it gluten dude all the all
the food in my work is
like plant-based meals and they're all
like so [ __ ]
good dude it's kind of insane like wait
you have food
at juice land yeah it's like
pre-packaged food and i get one of those
for lunch
nice and they're they're pretty good
like uh
unplugged why
um so wait you just turned mine really
loud so uh yeah
and have you ever had jackfruit
uh jackfruit is like this it's i think
yeah it's a fruit
it's like a really it's like it doesn't
really
it doesn't really have much of a taste i
mean it has a taste but it doesn't taste
like a fruit like it's like
and it's like really uh
like tough it's like meat it's like
it's kind of like has a consistency of
meat
and yeah and it's really good and you
can like season it and [ __ ]
um jackfruit and it's like high in
protein
yeah it's a really good meat alternative
is that what
jack fluge calls his balls jackfruit
um yeah but you should try it okay
this is the grocery hour with riley and
hans
next i like
uh food a lot yeah you're always cooking
sometimes not always elaborately when
you do cook
it's like it's like a chef it's like
everything's flying yeah i'm messy i'm a
messy i'm a messy in the kitchen
you're like uh you got two things going
and it's all worthless you're not
explaining yourself at all it's just
like
this is what i gotta do oh here i'm
doing it
onions cucumbers tomatoes whatever you
want
come on down to riley's kitchen
we got uh we got the blandest food made
the
by the blandest person we got
pass we got a pasta with sauce we got
cereal we got egg roll we got
coke
so um do you like sitting at restaurants
like do you like
um being at restaurants or do you like
to go
i like eating at restaurants yeah me too
a lot of people don't
a lot of it's an experience you get to
stare at strangers
yeah i like it it's nice and you get to
be weight weighted on
for the price wait for me extra
and you get to have a conversation in a
different area yeah you're forced to
have a conversation
yeah i would hate to do it alone
i like doing it alone if i like i'm
watching like if i can
if i'm like i like doing it alone
i just feel like socially it's such a
weak position no
it's not that's no way it's not you
don't have to you don't stare at people
you share your phone or like
you just kind of like what's the point
if you can stare at your phone at home
why do it in the restaurant because you
like this you like the
you like the food to be fresh and you
like the to eat off the plates that they
have and then the drinks that they serve
and you know you like uh
you'd like to be waited on isn't that
weird that we're like
all the time i do that all the time
alone in a restaurant when we're alone
at home
all the time it's like just because you
can see me
doesn't mean i'm less of a loser like
we've all yeah
oh you didn't come here with someone you
didn't
get someone to rearrange their schedule
and meet you here
just so you can talk about random
[ __ ] you didn't do that less of a
person
you're not making an event out of your
day like i am
you're not trying to you're not worth
like needlessly talking just to fill the
empty hole in your life
i know dude that's what i mean a lot
that's all like restaurant conversations
like
you don't really go deep in in
restaurant conversations like
maybe maybe if you know
you have more people but like just one
on one i feel like it's
it's just kind of just like ah you know
yeah as your b has your week been you
know
uh you know what are you are you gonna
get the taquitos or
the um burger or
what are you gonna get yeah
the only people who judge people who are
alone
are people who all they have going for
them is the fact that they came with
someone else
like the fact that they're always around
people they need people that distract
themselves from the fact that they're
doing anything with their life so they
judge people who don't have that
because they're like oh you don't even
have that well if i didn't have that i'd
be a loser so you must be a loser
but yeah we have other things going on
for us well um
i mean there is losers there is losers
like people who are alone uh
people who are alone are
probably more at risk for being a loser
than people who are
not alone you think
yeah being a loser alone is a special
type of loser
being a loser with other people at least
you have other people
but that's still not great like if
you're just like
a bug in in your social group just like
hey guys
and like you like are you too scared or
whatever yeah
like that guy looks like the mosquito
looks like a mosquito
yeah if you're that that's
depressing in its own way and in a more
harsh way because everyone's talking
[ __ ] about you
yeah that's not fun i hate
like that's what i don't like about
comedy there's a lot of like or open
mics there's like there's a lot of like
you gotta talk to you know some people
this spasticated
um yeah
do you i mean like do you think that's
like good to like be like
one group of comedians like two can we
all just be separate comedians like why
do we have to be like a group
i mean yeah i mean you're allowed to
splinter away that's the good thing
about
comedy scenes is that the rules don't
exist
you just make it however you want it and
turns out they're all the same because
everyone wants the same things
like there is no rule in comedy that you
have to do anything
socially there's no like
mandatory lunch meetings
yeah i know but like you it's just like
awkward not to i mean you're just like
sitting around for an hour
why did they do that like you like you
sign up an hour early and they're just
like all right
socialize
i don't i don't have time for that [ __ ]
it's so rude
especially when it's like two hours
ahead of time
yeah man it's like
weird sign ups here weird sign up
procedures here
that's because it's not a known quantity
they're still figuring out what what
works best for the scene and the size
um
sizing it shaping it up yeah it's
different
this is a different scene than new york
new york this
is where dreams are made of
there's nothing you can't do
when you're in new york new york
new york wow
do you miss new york city
um i miss like singing like
on the um
the light fixtures you know singing on
the light fixtures
you know i miss like
i miss uh you know
calling uh you know taxi cabs
yeah yeah rolling up to the rolling up
to the sharks
yeah this is our street corner boys when
you're a jet you're a jet all the way
is that that's you know no it's a
musical oh that's an actual song yeah
that's terrible holy [ __ ]
it was good in the 70s wow
puerto ricans but have you seen that snl
skit
no it's like uh it's like a gangster and
then
uh it's like why are we all singing
we should be shooting each other we're
gonna get him
we're gonna get it
[Laughter]
dude like musicals like there's no way
it can be like not kind of funny
yeah okay
it's like a whimsical world where
everyone's just happy
all the time not happy but like singing
yeah and singing is so vulnerable
yeah people don't want to share their
voice that much
well it's like it's like they're getting
into this like mindset
of like a different character
yeah acting is vulnerable
you have to completely disarm to be an
actor
or a singer what are you doing why are
you thinking about how andre rex tried
to tickle me yesterday
what i was just laying there in the
green room and he kept trying to tickle
me
that's how he absorbs your comedy that's
how he steals your jokes
i don't know how i was supposed to react
i don't know i'm just taking
them back to let it [ __ ] me
up they're like oh yeah that guy tried
to do that
yeah well that's this whole thing he's
just
sort of like coming at you sideways all
the time
um
hmm
[Music]
so yeah musicals are pretty
yeah so uh like
so do you know when you're like you do
when you're alone
like you do things that you don't do
like when you're
when you're with other people yeah
like jerking off no no i mean like uh
like if i was like with another person
like
i'd be like oh let's like watch tv or
like
yeah podcast or like you know let's do
something together and like
when you're with when you're alone
you're like you don't have to really do
you don't have the responsibility to
like do something
like you don't have to do anything you
don't have to like
collaborate in any way or you know
yeah and but like when you're with other
people the things you're
doing are like sometimes really
pointless like playing cornhole or like
watching netflix
and it's just like you're just like
getting off on the fact that there's
someone else there but you're not
actually doing anything
just like enjoying the fact that someone
else is there
um yeah but it's like but it's
actually a lot of times better than
being alone
because emotionally at least for me it's
just like when i'm alone it's just like
what's the point of being alone if i'm
not doing anything
yeah we're not supposed to be alone it's
really bad for us to be alone
that's not true definitely why because
we're social animals
and why did why do people say that like
what does that even mean
it means we always were in a tribe and
we always had
other people that doesn't mean we have
to always be like
hey do you want to go hang out on the
tribe that's not what you were just
saying
like you always love being with other
people
and being alone is sad yeah that's what
i'm saying i'm alone when i'm sad i'm
alone when i'm alone i'm sad
and so like when i'm with other people
i'm like
in a better place but i'm not really
doing that much more
than if i was alone you're strengthening
tribal ties
what's so important about that what's so
important about that if a jaguar comes
then they're more likely to save you
than if
you didn't talk to them but um
so what where's the jaguar it's like
a tow company or like oh my god
i forgot about that
i mean you have a friend group that was
willing to drive you
there to get your car out right yeah
that was super helpful
and that's like a jaguar you know it's
like
we're meant to be around other people
our brains are made
to be in a group setting we're always
bouncing ideas off
and when you're alone you don't have
that group so do you think we should
have like
everyone in the city of austin like
meets each other and like
so we can just all be one big group
that would help if we had like a rum
springer or like an oktoberfest
yeah well they probably they have like
they have [ __ ] like that probably
but they're just like the ability to opt
out of it
is very american yeah
and people will never be cohesive
because we
because we're [ __ ] yeah we made
being a recluse into our national
identity um
but you know that's not that bad either
it's like it's like okay you know do
whatever you want
we could be you know spain or we could
be like
coming together but if you don't guys
don't want to we don't have to
that was that like a city council
meeting like i mean we could just like
all hang out but like i mean whatever
you guys want
yeah but like don't feel pressured but
like
seriously like it would be kind of fun
yeah we'd love to see you
um we love you let's have like a a
city-wide sleepover yeah but there's
some people in austin that i don't want
to be friends with
but you should meet them maybe just say
hi we should say
they don't want to meet me unless
they're like a serial killer there's
like some
one percent of one percent that's like
totally evil what if this fly was
turning the wheel
it's like starting so um
what is the camera shut off no not yet
almost
what time is it it's 5 43.
um so
i mean what do you think what's your
favorite
what what do you think about this whole
[ __ ] scene and all the people in it
and how the country is coming out of the
pandemic
and how the comedy scene it shapes up
right now
i don't know what comedy is like i don't
really know
like just like it seems so i'm
i'm so involved with it i'm so involved
in it and yet
yet it still seems like so foreign to me
like the fact that people would buy
tickets to a comedy show
sounds seems like such a foreign concept
to me
even before the pandemic yeah
so it's like why would people pay
stand-up comedy is like
so crazy like it's just like
and people like it it's uh
i'm not saying it's bad it's just like
so freaky weird
i didn't even understand what it is
yeah it's just people going in a room
and then laughing and then
yeah the guy is just like it's like
we're just gathered here for no reason
other than just pure fun it's like
everything else is for on purpose
but it's also just like
none of us have to be here you know
yeah it's like a play
it's like someone pretending watch me
play do you want to come to my house and
watch me play can you let me play with
you
i'm gonna play with you
that's what yeah that's what i want to
do is like play
it's intellectual playing with words
child-like play playing with their
emotions
so but um do you think that you get
like better
by being around other people yeah at
better
thinking yeah you want to go
do that better at thinking
yeah i think so i think we're like made
to like
be part of a group group conversation
so to speak a group consciousness
that's why like you were that's why our
brains are so big is because we have to
deal with all the social relationships
and stuff
and uh you said like how when you're in
a big group the energy is different
that's what our brains are evolved for
like it's it's such a heightened
experience
yeah yeah um
yeah people are crazy dude like uh
people are like
different people
people are very different people they're
not even the same one as i am
they're completely different but it's
crazy like how different people
are yeah but it's crazy how
weird we are like why am i the way that
i
am like all the weird things that had to
happen to make this
could have easily not happened it's like
what a coincidence that i turned out
this way it could have been so different
well it's just like random it's just
like the way it turned out is the way it
turned out
i know it's so specific
so it's like i admit that i didn't even
have to be like this
so how many different possibilities are
there like i don't even feel like this
is like a
like a a standard default mode
to be so i'm like oh
there better be different versions of
people because otherwise we're [ __ ]
yeah yeah um
but yeah do you care like do you care
about other people
yeah who like
everyone yeah i mean whoever i have to
see
and running care what other people have
to say yeah
i mean i care enough but i don't like
i try to care the right amount you don't
want to care too much but you also don't
want to care too little
like if someone says good job you're
funny set
i want to be like whatever you're just
saying that
it's just you just you just think that
but it's not actually true
i want to be like oh i do care that he
thinks that
i'm good um
[Music]
yeah there's like a homeless person
that's like
i'm so poor give me everything then you
don't want to care too much
dude well uh
yeah i'll be like talking to someone and
like and they're like telling me about
their experiences like where they're
from like what
like i don't know just like getting to
know them like
in a conversation but then but then like
a friend who i know even more
a friend who i already know yeah it's
like
over there and i want to go talk to them
and i don't really want to talk to a
stranger anymore
yeah but like you know
um you know what it's rude um
but it's like i care what they have to
say but like not
you know not that much like
uh i care what you have to say but but
like you have to do that to become
friends with someone and it's just like
it's like becoming it's like
i don't know becoming friends with
someone like
is sometimes it like it feels like
obligatory like yeah
i'm not just going through the motions
i'm like yeah
i mean it's friend activity number two
now i will
i was like yeah yeah i might as well
look at yeah like i have to i have to do
this
i have to yeah we're not supposed to
make new friends we're supposed to be in
a tribe
where we already know people and then
expand those
you're expanding the tribe friendships
but like getting to know new people is a
thing that we have to do
especially in our generation because
we're moving around so much
and people are moving around so much
uh and there's not enough money in the
economy for us to stay in one spot and
have like a stable thing
we have to move to where the money is
uh so we have long-term friendships like
other generations did
uh don't you like
um don't you like not talking to people
because you
um like don't really like
you'd rather just like not think about
anything at all
talking to people i don't like talking
to people because i'd rather
not think about anything at all
isn't that like depression
maybe i mean
i think it's good to not think that's
what sleeping is for
there's plenty of time to not think in a
day but when you know
like when you're like i'll wake up and
i'm like ah i'm right back into thinking
[ __ ] i don't
i'm thinking again i'm like i'm thinking
so hard like i don't want to do
this like i don't want to be thinking
like in my patterns
my patterns of thinking i don't want to
go right back into that
yeah it's just full gear right away
maybe it's because
the rest of your life is depressing and
if you
had a good life you wouldn't be so uh
reluctant to start your thinking
patterns because you'd have
better ones but since we live in a
capitalist
hellhole i think you can make a good
life out of anything
you can but if you're not enjoying
thinking
then it probably means that there's
something about your life
that you're not happy with yeah my
thinking
but where does that come from me my
brain i'm making it up
and also your environment what's
happening around you
no it has nothing to do with it i'm like
of course it's like irrational
thinking you're a machine built to
navigate the world around you
the world around you has a very deep
effect on
what you're thinking i think the camera
turned off
it was low on battery really yeah i have
another battery
you want to just do audio only sure
i mean don't you think that you could
have a have like a more healthy life
like joe rogan and then you wouldn't
not want to think um
well i'm thinking about stuff that's not
particularly
in reality i'm thinking about like
things that i make up
that i'm scared of yeah maybe if you're
more in reality but reality requires you
to not think as much
yeah so that isn't that what you're
looking for it should just be in reality
yeah think as much but if reality isn't
that great then you're going to want to
go into your imagination which is full
of darkness
uh well
uh that's why i need to change my
pattern of thinking
is not to think about the dark things
i mean dark hearts maybe you could admit
like what is wrong with
the environment that you're living in
and then
do your best to fix it or not
well so what is the why um
i mean what what is what is what do you
think my ideal environment is
one with lots of friends and women i
haven't
no you don't yes i do you're going to
juice land
you're here alone i have friends at land
but you're not in like a
live living space with like a
but all your friends around yeah i am no
you're not
you're only here that's only one that's
not enough derek's here ethan's here
they're friends that's not enough i'm
imagining a bigger situation
you want me to live in a house without
you maybe describe it or not
or are you just going to pick holes in
it i'm wondering what it is you're
describing
i'm describing like a commune and
you there's like campfires every night
there's like a
place where you can log you can chop
wood
this is like a tree the new frontier
it's like a summer camp
but like you but like there's people at
that camp i wouldn't get along with
yeah i'm sure you wouldn't get along
with some of them but
then they would mysteriously disappear
like this is your ideal environment i
feel like
that's where you would shine so who's in
charge of
who gets to stay there like it's just
like a computer program that's like
oh if we let this guy stay riley's
happiness goes down five points
let's just divert him yeah but like then
you like
other people are involved so other
people are just like i like this guy but
i don't like this guy
i'm you're asking me where i think you
would be happy like i don't understand
how
it would happen but this is what i think
you need
is like a rich group of people to help
you
uh that aren't drunk comedians
who are open makers why do you think
that would help me
because then you'd be around healthy
people and then you would also become
healthy because you're around
healthy happy i am around healthy people
open my comedians
jewish land juice land exploited
employees
uh well you know
the comedian dude the comedians here
aren't that bad like they they have jobs
and [ __ ] like
most of them like they're not like
trunks
but they could have better jobs we could
have more money
well we're all trying to succeed at
comedy
yeah i mean where do you think you'd be
happiest
a palace of of my own rule
i think that'd be like hitler you'd turn
evil
not a giant palace
a good sized medium
sized palace like a uh
like a concise like a
concentrated palace a concentration camp
you're creating a nightmare no i mean i
want
i want it to be my space but i
yeah i want other people to be there
like other people that i know and trust
to use that space
to use the bathrooms and stuff i want it
to be
my oasis of good vibes only
yeah i mean i would think that you would
do well in a society that was built like
the garden of eden
and not like having people
be so poor in it i think if there's poor
people in the world
people deprive i like prosperous people
yeah um but yeah i mean i think
that uh some of your problem is from
outside of yourself
[Music]
maybe i don't think that's true i think
i think you can i think you could be
satisfied
alone no matter what but it's harder if
it's harder but in certain circumstances
it's easier to rely on someone else
but if you're living in like a [ __ ] pile
would you be like
oh why am i so depressed i should just
think harder
or would you be like okay i live in a
[ __ ] pile i'm going to be somewhat
depressed
so let's just take that for granted and
not like torture myself
that i feel like [ __ ] all the time
because of course i would and then let's
like
just be okay that i feel like low levels
of anxiety
and then just like go on from there like
not just try to cure myself
yeah that's the ideal yeah that's so
good yeah
yeah that's that's what you should do
but i can't it's hard to do
maybe that's why you're so uh sensitive
and introspective is because you just
have to
battle all these battles i'm like
fighting
wars in my mind are you really battles
do you think that yeah i mean i'll make
you better in the end
i mean i think it's like aged me because
like i've just been thinking so much
why why are you so different from other
people
where do you think everyone is going to
do this
i think uh i think most everyone is kind
of going through the generally the
the same thing existentialism
um and i'm not i'm not saying i'm like
one of a kind i'm just saying my brain
probably thinks more than like your
brain
i mean to not not like not let me think
think just like a general term but like
my brain like
uh
like think about certain things thinks
about certain things more than your
brain
thinks about those things what if i
already thought about it when i was 22.
did you really probably do but like
uh oh i didn't know that
what is it that you're thinking about
it's so intense
i'm uh
just like making things up like making
things to hurt me like things like make
like fears
like saying like these these will come
true your fears will come true
no don't you think it's because like
you're younger and you are just
embarking
on this journey and you don't know
what's in store so your mind is just
preparing you for
the worst calamities
[Music]
well i feel pretty prepared
at this point do you think that
uh you can make it if you go to
more mics you make it if you try
just climbing up the ladder um
it's hard to like zone out it's hard to
like turn that off
it's like i'd rather just like sit here
and then
and then be like not think at all and
then that's more comfortable than being
out
doing mics and then really just thinking
like being scared
because then you have to confront
what you're doing and be like oh yeah
this is what i'm doing with my life
um yeah another [ __ ] too just like
you have to like interact with the world
and the world scares me
yeah but um
what choice do we have and
a human's ultimate purpose is to
make the world a better place
and the fact that there's so much to fix
about the world
makes our job easier and that we can
just start anywhere
and start fixing it so it's like in some
ways it's
easier to just live in this world where
doing anything positive is
already way better than average
that's true to your point
yeah um but
these you have to be strong enough to
fix the world
you have to be strong enough to do that
um i think we are
we are the only ones alive in this
generation
yeah i mean not us too
just like you know we have life
that's true but like exist yeah that's
true
but it's not as exciting as it you know
it's not that exciting a lot of times
fixing the world what do you think
you're fixing the world
for or from or i don't i don't know
what i want to fix out what would i do
all right i wanna
chill um
produce good vibes
i'd rather just lay here than not exist
you'd rather not exist but that's like
our power is that we exist i don't owe
that
i don't why would why do i owe that to
others to
why do i owe that to the world that i
have to fix it
because there's nothing else that feels
better than that so
even true yes
even if you just try to get your dick
sucked and get a lot of money
you're going to be so depressed like
everyone who does that is
there is there's it's a short-term
solution to happiness but
the long-term solution is to help others
because then uh you get to do it for
longer and it's not as
a big of a jolt well
so who do you think helps others joe
rogan
how he books them on [ __ ] he has them
open for him
he's opening up a new club he has a
podcast where he like features people
that he thinks the world
should know who else
uh who else is helping people
um brian redband helping me
uh who else is helping people
like like feminists who are working in
social
offices like taking care of
kids nannies so what do you want to help
with
i want to help with
bringing the world to a place where we
take care of each other um
so why are you doing that i am
how by telling people that
fighting with each other is pointless
yeah i guess that's true i have thought
about that more
i've thought about communism a lot more
since i've met you
i know it's all i talk about
i mean it's not really communism
it's more like democracy
a helping hand yeah
um
okay what should i help with you should
help
with making really good comedy
is that a help yes
but it's um it's not as much of a help
as like feminism and politics and
it's kind of just like okay that was
funny all right seriously
but you have a different path where
feminists
are saying really helpful things but
they don't have like
a big audience like you're saying very
small
helpful things but to a big audience it
should be the other way around
well you can have both if you're good at
comedy like bill hicks was
it's like where you're saying important
things and you're entertaining people so
more people want to come
yeah but right now i mean that's true
where i'm i'm not
at that level yet
so i'm just saying whatever
i'm sacrificing you have to be smart to
do that though
um you have to be like really smart like
larry the cable guy
like obama
but you are smart it's like
just like work you get smart by doing it
smarter than i am smarter than a fifth
grader
it's like yeah i'm it's like you know
people would like lose that show all the
time it's just like yeah like
i'm uh i'm smarter than like an average
fifth grader not these like
super ultra nerd fifth graders who you
like found out of like a [ __ ] these
fifth graders on steroids yeah
like what what did you feed these kids
like these aren't normal fifth graders
these are just like super jerks
yeah who are going around making adults
feel so gonna get some ice cream
sure where's a good ice cream place
i have no idea you know mexican ice
cream
i think it's just like ice cream with
water
sugar water frozen sugar water i'm not
sure about that though
um i feel like uh we should have a show
called are you stronger than a fifth
grader and it's where you try to beat up
a fifth grader
but you don't need to know trigonometry
to function as an adult
[Music]
we should get more mics
i wish we had that flexible arm because
then we could just like
we could just be right here with it yeah
i can use my own flexible arm
the other day i was watching this trail
of ants and i was like watching them
like communicate and they like
they go in this line they like go back
and forth this line like a highway and
they just kind of like
like they'll stop with other ants and
like kind of like finger each other and
like
i guess like communicate somehow
and then but they do that with certain
ants but
they do that with like some of the ants
but not all of the ants
and i was like thinking i was like maybe
that's just like like
they're just like oh there's like hey
yeah and there's something that's in
this
hey greg
oh hi uh hey rebecca hey natasha um
let me finger you oh look at that aunt
oh look at that thorax that girl got a
thick thorax
and do you think real quick
do you think they can see us ants yeah
do you think they know who we are
yeah that's crazy bro
maybe not do you think they care they
really care about us
do you think they view us as a threat
yes
not really though we're not much of a
threat like because they're everywhere
bro and they're
like ants like they know what to do
yeah they're they're in the bottom
they're small
they're like one organism if they knew
us
that well they knew would to not come
into our house and like
eat our [ __ ] um
i mean a lot of they just know what's in
front of them
i don't think they can see us but the
queen like the whole organism
fbi there's something bigger going on
yeah
you ever feel like you're just a worker
bee
the people need to know no it's not time
let them dig let them learn from
let the hide them from the dark truth
hide them from this empty empty world
full of all these ants died in 911
that was orchestrated by our government
kill him
they must never know but you need a
rebel
in your society you need
one or two hey and he's like he's like
the ant was like the
he's like the taking pictures like with
like the 40s newspaper
kid i'm telling you i can't really do
that kid i'm telling you it's not going
to work
it's like he's like come on the evidence
is right here
get the [ __ ] out of here this is the
news i'm not talking
i'm not with your [ __ ] conspiracies
and [ __ ]
and he gets kicked to the curb it's like
raining and then he runs into this guy's
like
[Music]
he's like a dark figure and he's like uh
he's like i know
i know i know you can talk to
and then he brings him to like
rick and morty this
is uh aunt aunt and morty
this is antarexic native ant
and an anti-elation yeah
uh what's that movie with guy pierce
memento
memento
[Laughter]
oh you got it you want to call it a
podcast
i'm going to call it a slippery slippery
slope i'm hungry i could eat i could eat
a
hungry person you want to get an a you
want to get ice cream
you have your show when time's your show
eight o'clock
can i come yeah please do
to the vulcan this will be out after
because i can't edit it that quick but
i'm editing christy's
podcast that we did it's gonna be out
i'm gonna put it up it's probably done
rendering
oh no dude it's it has sensitive
information
what's what what what sensitive
information
holly johnston what about her what do we
say about her uh
no we were just like talking [ __ ] about
people
yeah what's wrong and
now we're doing that again now we're
talking [ __ ] about ourselves
uh
so do you think that uh we should
uh go is there another mic tonight
i know that's it you think anyone's
hanging out we should go to the creek
after the vulcan
everyone's probably hanging out there oh
no i'm scared
why because i don't like interacting
with people and putting myself out there
um okay yeah but it wouldn't be cool to
see just in terms of like
uh force like a migration of birds
or like a flock of seagulls it's like
look at all these people it's just cool
to be watching them
have you seen mummy yeah is it good
yeah no way there's no way it's good i
mean i saw it when i was young so it was
no way a movie about a [ __ ]
mummy it's called the mummy and it's
with brendan fraser
and it's a mummy dude that's so terrible
stupid it's like the type of gore it is
is very specific to egypt
it's like beetles getting under your
skin and being trapped in a sand
oh that's so racist i know they pretty
much
much made egypt egypt have gun violence
too
probably they do they have really oh
really they have
fast cars and they they don't give a
[ __ ]
that's how you can tell if a society is
badass as if they have fast cars
and they don't give a [ __ ] i have fast
cars
and i don't give a [ __ ]
and they always say my friend and do
cocaine and they're all rich
would you like some strawberries my
friend my friend you must take some
strawberries my friend
my friend i'm from egypt strawberries
all right let's go i'm hungry we did an
hour